إذن ما مدى ثقتك في التوجه إلى نصف نهائي البطولة في نهائيات روسيا في بطولة أوروبا ، هل يمكنك الفوز بالماشية بشكل جيد ، وهذا يجب أن يكون هدفنا لأن معيار ما هو متوقع الآن قد تغير بالنسبة لنا قبل هاتين البطولتين اللتين نحن لم نكن متأكدين حقًا مما سنحصل عليه ، حيث كنا نذهب إلى حيث كيف سيتعاملون مع هذه البيئة الجديدة مع اليورو ، لقد كنا على ظهر جائحة ونحن في المنزل كيف سيذهبون إلى التعامل مع ضغوط ذلك الآن ، أصبح الفريق في مكان مختلف قليلاً ، لذا يتعين علينا دائمًا التركيز فقط على الأداء وبعد ذلك يتم بناء كل شيء من هناك حقًا ، من غير المجدي أن نتطلع إلى الأمام ولكن بالطبع لا جدوى من ذلك إذا لم نكن كذلك. في محاولة للفوز بها ، يتم الحديث عنها حول القضايا خارج الملعب في قطر ، والمخاوف بشأن حقوق العمال وقضايا حقوق الإنسان ، ما مدى أهمية كرة القدم في رأيك في هذه البطولة ، أعني في نهاية القدم.  كل شيء هو كل شيء
، ولهذا السبب نحن هناك ،
إنه ما نحن موجودون للقيام بذلك ،
للأسف نحن في وقت
يمكن أن نلعب فيه ضد أي
عدد من البلدان ونثير
قضايا حقوق الإنسان و  بالطبع نحن بحاجة إلى
أن نكون على دراية بها ، يجب أن نعلق عندما يكون
ذلك ممكنًا إذا كان بإمكاننا إحداث
فرق ، فلدينا بعض
المسؤولية ، لكنني ذهبت إلى
قطر عدة مرات والتقيت
بالعديد من
العاملين هناك و  إنهم
متحدون في أنه شيء واحد بالتأكيد هو
أنهم يريدون إقامة البطولة
ويريدون ذلك
لأنهم يحبون كرة القدم يريدون
أن تأتي كرة القدم إلى قطر ولكن علينا أيضًا
أن نكون واقعيين بشأن
مدى تأثيرنا.  في بلد
لا نعرفه ، نحن لا نتحكم في ما
هو أفضل سيناريو من حيث
التأثير الذي ستحدثه هذه البطولة ،
هل تعتقد أه لا أعرف حقًا
لأنني لست خبيرًا أفهمه
المسؤولية التي تقع على عاتقي وباعتباري اتحاد كرة
القدم لدينا  أرسلنا إلى مجموعات حقوق الإنسان
حول ما يرغبون في رؤيته
ونحاول دعم هذه الأفكار من خلال
تعويض العائلات التي فقدت
عمالًا ومركزًا لحقوق العمال ،
لذلك نحن ندعم الأشياء
التي طُلب منا دعمها في بعض الأحيان  هذا
علنيًا وصوتيًا وفي بعض الأحيان يكون
ذلك
في مكان خاص حيث يجب أن تحدث الاجتماعات والتغيير ،
يجب أن أكون دائمًا
محترمًا عندما أتحدث كسفير
لبلدنا عن بلد آخر ولكن
أيضًا لفهم
أنك تعرف مختلف أه
دولة مختلفة أفكار مختلفة للدين
لذلك من
الصعب أن تعرف بالضبط ما الذي سيتغير